to get there all right
this is losers final of the tournament
genuine gaming saint going up against
infested here uh and of course invested
rocking that [ __ ] rum saint has been
picking dragon's nest when it's his
opportunity pick but this time to get it
on random so a little bit of luck on the
same side here this is losing final so
we'll be first to three games
game on round one
right
this is best of five
first three so have a long set here
oh
three of them
he could have done that again
oh why do it again when you get running
down for two the next time
oh man dude
still on a tear
it seems like such a
simple game plan right
like yeah i'm just gonna downpour three
and down one hey chad y'all do it too
yeah i want some back dad cancel it
and you're right that deceptive range is
it's actually really useful for this
match where he's fighting against the
you know pokemon's three
so long that's true right now state at
the wall though
trying to fight his way out
he's like no backswing for you
yeah
all right tied up in rounds
uh yeah we've seen him played both
thousands right extremely turtle and
extremely aggressive against jdc at
least when he was falling behind uh when
the gameplay wasn't working out so so
far you know i'm kind of a mix between
the two i want to get things here
oh
night up
zayn
he's gonna get
oh punish oh yeah yeah
yeah there we go
down four two three i believe minus 11
right uh on block so if you don't duck
the second hit because there is a little
bit of mix up there you still get a
punishment
yeah
saint
good start to this round oh and the
class has a whip punishment wow clap
pointing for the jet kick that was tight
get off the head gun
head butt so fast so sudden
wow
it's safe
damn is looking good today man he's
looking
really good he's very strong
infested is looking like his gas tank is
running low right now you know he needs
to refuel uh you know he
used his whole tank to get past me and
john ding and cherry berry mango got to
jdcr and he was like just starting to
run out of gas like oh
out of gas right uh so right now he's
got he's got to figure something out
because you know he's lost four games in
a row now three straight to jdtr and now
one the same so it's uh it's not looking
pretty
yeah the only moments that he was able
to get anything started was when he was
able to bully uh saint into the corner
at the wall and he was able to keep some
pressure there but i just feel like um
saint's just able to fight his way out
and uh and start his mix-ups and yeah
he's just getting uh yeah everything's
still working for saint you know it's
you know it's still there so we'll see
if we do have uh more games uh against
infested this is best of five so
yeah
and maybe maybe we will see a negan
i would i wouldn't mind could be
i mean if he loses this next game i feel
like he's got to try negan after that
but
it's gonna be [ __ ] wrong still here
and you know the character focus he's
fine right he's got the options to do
everything yeah um yeah and the
offensive strategy from saint it's it's
straightforward it's simple right uh but
defensively he's playing fantastic right
and that's what's separating out here uh
whether the defense can keep up
with infested's offense
and so far so good
twilight conflict so switching things up
here too right uh we've seen him go to
bunch
yeah that's all for the balcony on the
stage
gotta balcony break it also that's true
man looking for the timing on the
downpour too that's such a jack player
thing to do
oh
there you go
wow other side get up three
yeah just switch sides like that
the mix-ups finishes the whole
pull that out
doing what pokemons do
yeah and the follow-up damage can land
on the wall you know it's yeah
ridiculous
that move probably needs to be adjusted
look at that see it's launch punch who's
doing it you know yeah everyone's just
doing jasmine so fast
at the wall
oh
threatening heartbreak
you have to punch one gander with canned
perry which would be pretty tight too
right
here
he does have to pay for the drive nice
blocks yeah wow
still not really yet he got the launch
stage are you gonna clutch out this
round too oh my god hell yes he is
fight all right
same with the clutch block and down
forward look at them
wow the ducking approach there give me a
lucky you'll give me alone
yeah manfest has committed to downforce
all day he's like man your downforce is
so annoying i'm just my downforce
i'm gonna do it back to you he's
literally trying to play the same game
back at him right yeah
he's like it's like getting to him
oh
no no doubt this is my game
that's sneaky halloween
2-0
i guess invested this is yeah saints
momentum is great i'm actually worried
if he if he wins this like hey jdcr
probably noticing this this momentum
that that saint has
i mean it's
it's crazy i just feel like nothing can
stop him right now at this point
at the same time you say that though i
feel like
jd is probably watching and laughing you
know i feel like he's like that's not
gonna work and me you know like of
course he's gonna do it there like he
knows saints so well both of them know
each other so well
uh so i mean
it seems like that's where we're headed
right it seems like saints gonna run
through
infested right now he's gonna make him
jdcr we're gonna get a classic 2017
match in 2021 out here
but the fest is not done yet right the
fakamon now oh to invested his own five
since reaching the winners final so yeah
he needs to change something it might be
a character switch time maybe not but
really right now i don't know if it's
even gonna matter because the offense
from saint is what's winning him
everything right like defensively his
defense is always there anyway but the
offense is just a downpour three down
for one of the downfall twos especially
the downfall two game from saint is
really what's turning things around here
yeah against everybody
yeah and
yeah he's definitely been able to crack
through infestes uh investors defense
and we were talking about how strong his
defense was how patient of a player he
was but it doesn't matter because yeah
saints just getting in there and
frustrating him and uh
you know tagging him with lows whenever
he wants however he wants
getting to his head all right
yeah infested has to make something
happen here he's down uh
two games
nice back dash
that's gotta be [ __ ] around the whole
way huh
finishing the string
yeah infested not being able to
capitalize on on his frame advantage
[Music]
make some adjustments
he was so ready for that
oh i'm now at the wall oh look at that
he wants an
the attack
message with rage though
oh but saint doesn't care just
pushes on takes that round
fight
down two starts the round off
backswing blow down forward yeah
yeah
i'm not gonna reach
squeeze and you get the block no you can
take the downfall i think downfall is
getting there
oh you were just talking about downpour
two games
ah but no no no conversion from that he
clapped his toenails or something dude
that was crazy yeah yeah three of them
yeah
oh man and you're saying like he's been
just being offensive but like yeah he
has his defense to pull it out whenever
he needs
okay
and he knows that it makes up time to
punish daddy look at this block and
headbutt punish
oh my god y'all all sleeping on my gang
are you what you thought i was done
just like that three times
makes it at the grand finals to face
jdcr in winners
yeah that's a that's a great way to
to end the the game i mean just like
yeah the ultimate call out right just uh
his his foot was like right and he was
like smelling his foot when he did that
that radar it was so clean just barely
just all of it